[Musique]
bonjour liant pelletier bonjour vous
êtes vice président des républicains
et merci d'avoir accepté l'invitation de
lci soyons le civil et polis en déverser
l'humanité de cet entretien
l'actualité c'est la condamnation hier
par le tribunal correctionnel de paris
de nicolas sarkozy à un an de prison
pour corruption et trafic d'influencé
comment réagissez vous à cette
condamnation moi je crois profondément
la séparation des pouvoirs entre
l'exécutif le législatif et le
judiciaire et j'ai jamais eu l'habitude
de commenter des décisions de justice
pour autant quand certains juges se
mettent à faire de la politique
le rôle des élus du peuple c'est de le
dénoncer fortement est pour moi comme
beaucoup de français d'ailleurs
spontanément je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi
cette décision me semble insensé
disproportionnée extravagantes
d'abord sur le fond y at il un corrompu
y at il un corrupteur y at il des
preuves
j'ai lu le délibéré du tribunal hier qui
parle d' un faisceau d'indicés graves
précis concordants qui continue
d'innover qui reconnaît qu'il n'y a pas
de preuve formelle c'est un faisceau
d'indicés ils disent vous pourrez
trouver précis factuel ce faisceau dndi
se constitue voilà ce vers quoi il fait
ça mais en démocratie dans un état de
droit
est-ce que des indices une addition d'un
disque constitue une preuve c'est déjà
un premier débat au fond d'un
l'impression d'ailleurs que ces juges là
on rejouait maladroitement
le sketch de coluche on s'autorise à
penser dans les milieux autorisés qu'un
accord secret pourrait être signé
prochainement mais on n'est pas sûr
pour quelqu'un qui nous commande de
pompiers je ne fais jamais vous pourrez
d'ailleurs le vérifier mais ils ont
décidé de franchir la ligne rouge de la
politisation de la justice le rôle des
élus du peuple
c'est de dénoncer cette réalité la
deuxième raison vous le savez bien
d'ailleurs c'est la proportion de la
peine trois ans vous l'avez dit dont
deux ans avec sursis à un an ferme
quand on sait que quotidiennement tous
les voyous qui s'en prennent aux
français à nos forces de l'ordre à nos
élus sont ou pas poursuivi ou bénéficie
d'un non-lieu ou parfois peut-être un
simple rappel à la loi
je me souviens parle en août dernier
saab avait marqué les 158 casseurs à
paris qui avait été interpellé
rappel à la loi cet individu qui c'est
qui avait frappé violemment un maire le
5 août
rappel à la loi on voit bien qu'il ya
drid disproportion et puis enfin c'est
une question politique je pose là la
question du parc national financier qui
je le rappelle a été fondé par françois
hollande dont même la présidente eliane
houlette reconnaissait en juin dernier
devant les parlementaires
les pressions qu'elle avait subis de la
part du parquet et du gouvernement dans
la sphère françois fillon maître
dupond-moretti
avant même d'être garde des sceaux qui
en reconnaissait je cite les méthodes de
barbouzes et on peut s'étonner par
exemple que la seule enquête qui a été
menée contre les proches des manuels
macron l'occupant l'occurrence alexis
colère pour conflit d'intérêt a été
classée sans suite bref moi je pense que
le parc national financier a vécu parce
que il affaiblit l'idéal de justice
quand le poison de la politisation et de
la partialité pèse sur la justice alors
il n'y a plus de justice ce matin ce
n'est pas le parquet national financiers
qu'ils tombent débat jeudi ce que vous
en pensez du parquet national financier
c'est très bien
mais c'est la 32e chambre
correctionnelle du tribunal
correctionnel de paris puisque c'est
cette chambre là qui a condamné nicolas
sarkozy et vous dit les juges de cette
chambre là on fait de la politique
oui pour les raisons que je viens d mais
pourquoi ce qui ferait de la politique
pas de preuve ce qu'il n'aime pas
nicolas sarkozy parce qu'ils veulent
l'empêcher d'être candidat aux élections
présidentielles
pourquoi pourquoi ce serait de la folie
sera un jour à eux de répondre mais
l'acharnement dont est victime nicolas
sarkozy et c'est pour moi mais bon
beaucoup de français une preuve lourde
de du fait que nicolas sarkozy qui a
toujours dit la raison qui n'était pas
au dessus des lois n'est pas non plus en
dessous des lois il a le droit
d'ailleurs en cet instant le fait qu'il
fasse appel interjette appel annuler le
jugement sur le jeu hier il est donc
dans cette instance est un ingrédient et
ordinaires innocents mais il n'empêche
autant de moyens déployés et puis c'est
l'an mil du pouvoir qu'il est rien
comment ces l'emmène du pouvoir qu'ils
rien à depuis le temps que je me montre
que je pense depuis longtemps que
françois hollande et ses amis et
peut-être voulons son âme un îlot voie
lente quand il crée il a aucun point
hollande françois hollande quand il crée
le parquet national financiers en 2013
et 2014 jouer aujourd'hui joue par la
chambre correctionnelle qui combien
nicolas sarkozy ça n'a rien à voir avec
le parquet il est des juges
hélas et je le regrette je ne mets pas
en cause la majorité des juges
il est des juges cela ceux qui ont jugé
cela un qui utilise la justice à des
fins politiques pour abîmer salir et
humilié l'homme d'état qu'est nicolas
sarkozy je vous propose pour poursuivre
cette conversation d'écouter le
président des républicains
christian jacob qui a posé la même
question que vous à sa façon mais
j'aimerais bien que vous essayez d'y
répondre christian jacob
c'est de l'acharnement c'est
indiscutablement de l'acharnement
quand on est face à un tel acharnement
une telle disproportion de la peine à
qui est-ce que cela profite à qui est ce
que c'est le profit d' l'avenir le dira
on attend trop facile ça non mais c'est
trop facile
je veux dire je suis pas madame irma est
ce que je ne parle pas sans preuve
est ce que je dis que je peux décoder ce
que vous dites si les juges font de la
politique
oui mais si ça profite à quelqu'un
installer manuellement cours des trois
prochains jours je les ai évoqué et donc
je pense que j'évoque je n'ai pas de
preuve formelle jeudi que l'outil du bnf
qui a été imaginé par attendez laissez
moi finir qui a été créée par françois
hollande vous ya dans le contenu il ya
un grand oui j'ai tout le monde le sais
françois fillon d'être au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle et qui
continue de manière organisée et
méticuleuse à empêcher la droite et en
particulier nicolas sarkozy d'exister
tout cela pose un certain nombre de
questions christian à raison poser cette
question je la pose
l'avenir le dira et je dis simplement
aux français prenez du recul par rapport
à cette justice qui devient politique
essayons demain de bâtir une justice
profondément indépendante est juste mais
nous sommes d'accord pour dire je le
répète au risque de lasser mais que ce
n'est pas le parquet national financier
condamné nicolas sarkozy
m'enfin c'est le tribunal correctionnel
de paris après une audience que même les
avocats de nicolas sarkozy ont reconnu
bien menée par la présidente avec
distance et équité c'est le tribunal
correctionnel de paris qui comme nicolas
sarkozy et vous vous dites que c'est une
condamnation un sens c'est
disproportionné et extravagante parce
que les magistrats font de la politique
est tellement j'ajoute pourquoi ce que à
l'origine de la décision service des
maillots n'a qu'à l'origine de la
décision du tribunal vous le savez bien
jean michel aphatie il y a oui mais le
travail entre guillemets du parc
national financiers et fut j'espère que
la chambre d'appel invalidera cette
décision et rappellera le droit plutôt
que d'appliquer la morale donc c'est
leur moral c'est le tribunal
correctionnel qui fait de la politique
au service de qui
voilà c'est tout le monde le sait et
vous lui dites eux je voulais dire à
trois reprises
emmanuel macron peut-être et ses amis
emmanuel macron peut-être avez-vous
ajouté gérald darmanin ministre
l'intérieur a apporté tout son soutien à
nicolas sarkozy soutien amical mais tout
son soutien le ministre de l'intérieur
apporte tout son soutien à quelqu'un qui
viennent d'être condamnés par la justice
pour corruption et trafic d'influencé
est-ce que cela vous choque ou est-ce
que cela vous choque
je l'écouté avec attention chacune de
ces respirations de sévir guide pour
bien comprendre ce qu'il avait dit il
soutient l'homme sans rien commenté du
fond de la décision de justice je ne
vois pas en quoi il n'est pas dans dans
son rôle
vous disiez vous même tout à l'heure
vous faisiez un parallèle entre cette
justice qui ne condamne pas des
délinquants et qui condamne l ancien
président de la république est là on a
un ministre de l'intérieur qui pour
aucune autre personne condamnée ne lui
apporte son soutien il ya une différence
de traitement qui sait que peut-être que
gérald darmanin à les liens particuliers
et affectueux annick ans avec nicolas
sarkozy comme moi d'ailleurs
moi je crois me prouve ça justifie que
j'ai eu la chance et l'honneur
d'accompagner nicolas sarkozy se jugent
le plus gros serait je crois
profondément en saône honnêteté je suis
personnellement scandalisé qu'à partir
d' écoutes illégales entre nicolas
sarkozy et son avocat à partir
d'éléments de suspicion entre eux un
service et une information services jean
michel aphatie dont chacun sait qu'il
n'a jamais été rendu la fameuse
nomination de monsieur azibert à monaco
tout ça est lui né avec des moyens
financiers d coûte judiciaires
disproportionnées et pendant ce temps là
que fait-on des fiches et s et pendant
ce temps là que franck fait-on des
dealers dans nos quartiers populaires et
pendant ce temps là quels moyens dont
antoine aux gendarmes et de policiers je
veux donc enfin sanctionné ceux qui ne
respectent pas la loi dans notre pays
oui mon rôle d'élu du peuple
je dis bien du peuple et non pas des
élites c'est de dénoncer ce deux poids
deux mesures
si nous revenons demain au pouvoir notre
priorité sera de sanctionner ceux qui
pourrissent la vie des français et non
pas un ancien président de la république
dont chacun sait qu'il n'a rien fait les
élites je pense
inclus dans le peuple juste comme ça une
question de sémantique je ne me pensais
pas à je pense hélas non seulement que
le peuple de les en plus ce défi des
élites parce que les élites méprisent le
peuple et les élites ne font pas partie
du peuple français a de moins en moins
c'est une caste vous savez ils vivent un
patrie double non pas du tout j'ai
absolument pas dit ça disons que
comporte une gaffe transpo fonctionner
si le sentiment très sciences po ils ont
tous fait l'ena ils vivent ensemble
alors moi je ne me sens pas appartenir à
cette caste et je défends le peuple
français vous disiez qu'est-ce qu'on
fait des fichiers sur j'imagine qu'on
continue de les surveiller mais ça n'est
pas ma question est ce qu'un ministre de
la république parce qu'il a un lien
d'amitié avec quelqu'un qui viennent
d'être condamnés peut apporter son
soutien sous-entendu critiqué la
décision de justice sans que cela ne
choque personne
oui certes mais ça vous paraît possible
l'amitié est au dessus des principes
républicains
pas du tout je ne sais ce qui se passe
non je pense que l'expression tel qu'il
l'a formulée on était juste il a dit à
deux reprises et ne m'appartient pas de
commenter une décision de justice mais
je veux rappeler mon soutien amical à
l'homme qu'elle nicolas sarkozy nicolas
sarkozy aura encore à faire avec la
justice dans ce mois de mars avec
l'affairé bygmalion ça aussi c'est de
l'acharnement
ce procès ne devrait pas exister je
prends toujours la politique n'est pas
le fond du dossier on verra je parle là
de la décision oui hugo et vous parle du
présent semble et qu'est ce que c'est
dit est-ce que c'est non non excusez moi
oui vous aidant bygmalion c'est la
preuve supplémentaire de l'acharnement
de la justice ce procès n'a pas de sens
les juges là aussi forme de la politique
c'est ma question
ce qui est intéressant de noter c'est
qu'à ma connaissance n'est que la
sarkozie par la commission nationale des
comptes de campagne avaient déjà été
sanctionné pour un dépassement et donc
la justice tente à nouveau de sang-mêlé
on verra la teneur des débats
bon là je tourne déjà qu'on passe
beaucoup beaucoup de temps furnes sur
cet événement et qu'une fois de plus
tout est fait pour nous tenter de
détourner le regard sur l'essentiel je
le redis l'essentiel dont me parlent les
français c'est la question de l'islam
politique et de l'identité c'est la
question des fraudes sociales et
fiscales et 2 du rapport au travail
c'est la question de la dette et des
déficits c'est comment remet la france
comptera au travail qu'on défend enfin
celles et ceux qui bossent et qui se
lève tôt dans notre pays ce qui n'est
pas le cas comment met fin à haut
pouvoir de là
bureaucratie des hauts fonctionnaires
tant de choses essentielles pour réparer
la france là est l'enjeu
jean michel aphatie vous avez commencé
en disant les choses importantes islam
politique et identité vous fournissez
une transition pour le sujet suivant
vous avez noté sans doute parce que dans
le petit monde de la fait du bruit peut
être dit elle quelque chose de profond
dans le pays
une enquête de libération samedi qui
indique que pour beaucoup d'électeurs de
gauche il n'est plus question de faire
barrage à marine le pen en votant
emmanuel macron qu'ils se débrouillent
vous s'il y avait un second tour marine
le pen emmanuel macron ce que les
sondages indiquent de manière régulière
parce que ces deux partis ont des
électorats qui demeure de haut niveau
c'est à dire que le peuple continue de
soutenir dans les intentions de vote
l'idée d'une candidature de marine le
pen et l'idée d'une candidature d'
emmanuel macron c'est comme ça c'est un
constat
est-ce que vous aussi vous en avez marre
de faire barrage à marine le pen a
d'abord je ne fais pas de la politique
je me suis pas engagé en politique pour
faire barrage à madame le pen
je suis désolé de décevoir la pensée
unique et le politiquement correct je me
suis n'ont pas pas de vous vous avez
voté manuel accroc second tour en 2017
non j'ai voté blanc vous avez voté blanc
je refuse catégoriquement
ce duel que ces deux formations
d'ailleurs sans doute complice sur le
plan cynique tente de nous imposer
je crois une alternative cette
alternative
je l'appelle de mes voeux je souhaite qu
autour des républicains nous puissions
la bâtir j'appelle même à nouveau ce
matin à la création d'un bloc
patriotique qui rassemblerait toutes
celles et ceux qui ne veulent pas de ce
qu'incarne et de ce que mettent en
oeuvre emmanuel macron emmanuel macron
son bilan à mes yeux je dis avec
beaucoup d'humilité tout en
reconnaissant que c'est difficile avec
un peu de briller veux tu sais vous
allez vivre en prison
d'accord qu'est ce qui vous sépare
aujourd'hui papa vous spécifiquement
mais qu'est ce qui vous sépare
aujourd'hui de marine le pen elle a fait
des pages sur l'économie l'euro qu'est
ce qui vous sépare d'elle
beaucoup de choses vous l'avez évoqué le
rapport à l'europe le rapport à l'euro
de changer le rapport à l'europe au
rassemblement national jean-michel
aphatie quand même mais lille joue pieds
de marine le pen dans l'eau plusieurs
tours je lisais sur la za mentalement un
rapport à la chose publique
pourquoi je vaux mieux non mais attendez
je vous réponds que je suis bien placé
pour vous et vous pourriez vous
connaissez mon parcours oui que j'assume
j'ai commencé comme militant du front
national j'avais 18 ans puis j'ai
travaillé avec fierté pendant sept ans
aux côtés de vivre de villiers et je
suis depuis près de 13 ans au sein des
républicains avec nicolas sarkozy et
xavier bertrand a à l'époque et j'ai pas
changé de conviction sauf que lorsque
j'avais 18 ans la colère légitime sur la
situation que je vivais prenait le pas
sur la volonté acharnée de trouver une
solution à un problème
ce que je reproche mois fondamentalement
à madame le pen menacé de contester de
s'opposer parfois en disant des choses
justes d'ailleurs mais de ne jamais
tenter de trouver c'est compliqué c'est
dur c'est une exigence
j'ai été maire j'ai été président de
communauté de communes aujourd'hui
député de la nation trouver une solution
à un problème et notre marque de
fabrique a été républicain au groupe
parlementaire au sénat comme à
l'assemblée sur la question de l'islam
politique sur la question de la dette
sur la question de la bureaucratie sur
la question pour recréer par un écart
entre les revenus du travail et les
revenus de l'assistance et de faire des
propositions concrètes pour réparer la
france telle est notre défi comme vous
ne pourriez pas voter pour marine le pen
non et vous ne pourriez vous ne pouvez
pas voter non plus pour emmanuel
maintenant je ferai tout pour oui je
comprends vous ferez tout mais vous j'ai
voté blanc en 2017
vous ne pouvez pas voter pour emmanuel
macron et vous ne pouvez pas vous dire
je ne veux pas de ce duel je suis comme
les français je veux autre chose et
c'est autre chose est possible je vous
rappelle je vais prendre un exemple non
mariés des sondages xavier bertrand par
exemple est juste derrière
donc si les français veulent une
alternative et bien c'est avec les
républicains que nous pourrons la bâtir
la condition de rassembler toutes celles
et ceux qui aiment la france comme les
français vous ne voulez pas du vote
donnent duel marine
emmanuel macron mais c'est ce que les
intentions de vote indique pour
l'instant donc qui compte c'est les
suffrages en plus que des sandales vous
avez tout à fait raison merci d'avoir
avec cette personnalisation d'elle c'est
guillaume pelletier et maintenant ça
donne le temps avec vous ma réalité les
lits bonjour marie aline bonjour je